or counter this button to this video
sorry guess I need something to drink
yeah um yeah this is a 15 minute game
playing a laser sharp from the US yeah
we got him a ruler pest hmm yeah black
has such a huge choice at this point I'm
thinking if I could maybe try something
that I have not played yet on video hmm
and it should be something that I at
least know a bit okay let's try that
that's the bird variation not exactly
named after the animal because yeah you
know all openings that are named
according to and two animals are bad um
in this case it's after them I think the
English player
Henry Bert just like one F for the bird
opening named after this player okay
well is this a good line against the ROI
hmm
it's probably not the best line
available but it is playable sometimes
some being surprisingly and resilient I
have fun looked at this a while back and
it was surprised that this is
that this is a viable line actually
black will play c6 and possibly d5 later
and what black has is this pawn on d4
which is irritating white to some extent
the natural development in both Knight
c3 is not possible and it's quite
remarkable that black has some in some
lines even some space advantage oh yeah
he played castles there's also the move
Bishop c4 which might be a bit more
precise instead of castles at least
that's how I remember it
because if instead of castles he goes
Bishop c4 I cannot play Bishop c5
because a bishop takes f7 check so this
actually would would have prevented this
development
um I think here wider just goes d3 and
why not just yeah I'm just a good normal
move I think I think c6 is the move
yeah and now that's interesting now it's
this there are there are lines where you
can just play d5 and accept this this
double pawn I wonder if this is one of
those positions maybe it is going to I'm
going to try that surprisingly you
didn't have to take that is indeed not
what I expected hmm so well I can take
on e4 but then there is this Queen age 5
business arte our Bishop takes f7 Queen
h5 check business the c5 Bishop is
hanging maybe I could just play a 97 oh
that's funny he's asking me what the
name of this line is I just tell it ok
so Knight is 70 this seems switch safer
if he takes on d5 that's in fact
interesting should I just take with the
knight on
ok so I cannot take on a form because of
Queen f7 so it's probably castles you
know I guess castles
if he takes yeah I can take with the
pony even it's not in this line it's not
that terrible to have this double points
as they also restrict White's pieces but
it still if he takes on d5 you know I
can also just take with the night yeah
interesting
Knight X of course avoids the immediate
structural problem but I'm not sure it
it gives up c4 and deform let's let's
say 95 d is going 92 to e4 and if I take
with the pawn it's not so clear where
his pieces go I'm not sure that's a
tricky decision okay I'm doing that it's
a bit weird looking maybe but still yes
yeah I thought I go f6 and then Bishop
e6 possibly to f7 not much choice
otherwise I'll lose d5 and Bishop e6 II
many plays rook e1 and then I cannot
even play a six so you know Bishop to e6
I need to need to cover d5 and I need to
make this knight on his seven mobile
again so that I can play let's say
knight c6 possibly 95 or 96 okay so to
c6 or to g6 it all has some point to it
he's maybe playing he's maybe intending
94 actually could could be and could be
a point hmm maybe I should we treat this
just prophylactically so that 94 I can
really take you 6 was hanging so d
Bishop u6 check some I'm securing this
Bishop for the moment and then decide if
I go should I go to g6 or c6 he had the
good thing about those double pawns that
they they control some important square
Z 3 E 4 and so on
but obviously they're also in a way weak
that's a strange rules what's the point
of it I don't really understand at the
moment and it's even at a matter of
tactical liability here
can easily turn out to be some sort of
double attack like Queen a5 looks at the
knight and the bishop the bishop does
not have many squares which is in fact
quite often a problem in the blood
variation for white hmm Wow interesting
and I'm not really clear I'm not really
sure what this move is doing may be
preparing Knight to b3 but it looks
totally weird night on b3 Bishop on a4
I'm not sure I want to play knight c6
now he might just much Majesty get
Queen a5 however is pointless I think he
can just play Knight b3 taking c5
not not clear not clear or what I should
do I can play something like a six and B
five which is not not stupid maybe he
wants to control the aid so that rook e8
is not easily possible Queen g3 Bishop
c7 could also be an idea okay I'll do
that
this gives the the bishop a square on a
seven maybe this this can be useful and
F I've got b5 them why not push with b5
okay so b5 now right
so I've gained quite some space now on
the queenside
okay my idea was to knight c6 now I'm
not sure where else it could go which
looks like a decent square
okay tries to pin to double on the phone
yeah this can be a indeed a bit annoying
simply because I need to lend some
protection to the d5 pawn so let's say
Queen d7 rook e1 look he aids we
exchange everything and at the end he is
going to take d5 winning a pawn that's
not good
hmm okay I wonder okay well okay he can
go if he doubles on the e-file it's not
like he's threatening much on this only
seven for example it's not threatening
okay let's just do this
and rookie one I can I can try to play
on the queenside with a fire for example
a5 a4 Knight B form could be a could be
a weird but interesting idea I'm not
sure if it is any good though yeah well
rook e8 is really not good I mean I'm
giving away d5 that way I can play
Knight a5 and get this bishop but I'm
not sure about that can be a very tricky
the night on b3 might be a good piece to
check D for him I'm going and going with
that what I just had to describe okay
well this is I didn't expect I thought a
point before now would give me give me
good play okay let's not waste time
about that take more time on that I
think the correct way to say it but ok
now I'm taking a three and if he takes
Knight takes shows that assisted by this
double point black really has some play
on the Queen side yeah the blood
variation is not particularly brilliant
I mean white knows what what is doing is
probably has a slight edge or something
but it's a practical weapon people don't
know what to do simply some of them
probably have never seen the line like
the opponent here it's just not a good
idea to play the
this kind of line against the player who
has specifically prepared for that or is
known to be booked up tremendously even
in offbeat lines other than that you can
you can certainly try the line
yeah I'm a bit puzzled that he's not
playing at the moment it I would assume
that white mistake otherwise I'll take a
3-2 times and win a pawn I mean how do
you not play it takes before him not
sure at all
in them
as mentioned I'm threatening to take ba3
ba3 ruler Bishop III being a pawn up
okay so at the NT he played the move and
now if he goes Bishop to be one I
actually could play rook e8 he tells me
I should play a four and not only three
yeah that's probably right but that is
probably right okay now while a3 looks
active but I'm not sure that it is
really doing that much don't then I get
too much the question is is rupee a the
move should I exchange rooks am yeah
well hard to do to do without it
now I can as on d5 there isn't any any
pressure anymore
and my point to attack check long-term
is probably be Jen you know I will not
on threatening Queenie one for starters
winning a piece
Queenie one second I'd have won three
takes be one because of this awkward
Bishop Ian
you're not not quite sure but what white
should do now actually there are some
some serious issues here if white
for example plays a normal-looking move
like Age 3 this this this won't and this
will not end well
probably Bishop age 5 okay he's got G
form but that's already very machinist
oh wait wait wait wait wait if I go g 5g
5 bishop g3 Bishop Age riotous would win
out right here because of Queen e2 check
probably probably it would win not 100%
sure g5 bishop g3 besides the fact that
he can go somewhere else but okay g5
bishop g3 Bishop h5 Queen f6 community
to check King g1 Queen d1 Shack night f1
hmm yeah my king is terribly open he's
taken on their six already
mm-hmm not sure that this is so great if
I go Bishop h5 just like that there is
g4 mmm
hmm so that's too bad if I play g5
bishop somewhere and King g7 mr. smooth
just trying to gain some space okay I'll
do that for a minute 22 I need to speed
up a bit okay he does not necessarily
need to go to g3 maybe he's scared
Bishop d3 Bishop h5 Queen f6 but there
is no intermediate moves on anything
right I'm not sure okay well dad didn't
expect it it's a bit tricky interesting
tricky tricky tricky wants to go Bishop
d6 maybe
a bit of age five bishop age five is a
serious IDM
I'll do that okay maybe he can just play
queer Knight f3 if I then capture he
would need to take with the pawn okay we
didn't do that yeah three looks looks
really ugly but they're not clear if I
can can do anything about it
he's got this idea to play Bishop to d6
this is this is really something I
should prevent maybe just I'm just 27
it's not clear what hits night is going
this is yf3 I didn't really expect he
has little scope for his pieces at the
moment yes of course I will retreat the
bishop at some point to have seven or g6
again Bishop h5 was just for tactical
purposes
okay see three years at some point he
probably has to play that the question
is do I just retreat one do I have fun
something something I would have the
ordinary it looks like it looks a bit
like and there are maybe some tactical
shots yeah he's got to ship a two
unfortunately if I move the knight okay
two minutes it's starting to get a bit
tricky with the time
you figure was worship a tuna
hmm I really want to attack this Bush a
peon John so that it needs to move and
that reason my idea to play Bishop TD -
maybe I need to move the king somewhere
let's try that the bishop moves to c7 I
have bishop before for example that's a
strange move Queen c7 this idea
okay if I take it and play Bishop -
before what is
I don't know come on one-one minute
something I'm threatening to take that
and he has absolutely no square to go to
tweenage a tango bishop g6
all right see for Bishop b8 was weird
I don't see a move here really maybe 90
for the best practical trial but it's
it's of course basically just a piece
down
there's no problem is that after Bishop
takes d2 immediately threatening
threatening stuff yeah he's ignoring it
actually checkmate this this mate is the
immediate threat after Bishop d2 um this
was strategically very tricky this
position that's a good feature of this
opening at it leads to very interesting
and a somewhat unconventional play here
as he already said during the game a4
was better yeah I'm pretty sure about
that my intended response I'm not sure
if it is even any good was Knight to be
form which seems to fail due to c3 okay
okay mom maybe yeah I'm not sure if I
would have thought about that for very
long but not before c3 is good okay and
I don't really have a good Square to go
to it's a problem yeah that's just a
good move after this
the problem is that this is immediately
hanging okay I can make an make a please
sacrifice out of this which is some
however probably pretty ridiculous
well the compass just giving white a
slight edge so maybe it's not totally
ridiculous but okay not what I had
planned at home and this some yeah now
if I go here it's simply not working
this is also not great maybe something
like that okay so light before is
probably a nonsense idea and I should do
something else but before is not what I
intended
so probably 97 the idea was to to
actually get this traded and
have this this type of situation here
maybe you cannot just take it and no I
need to do this fund then take care this
was what I wanted to get and it happened
in the game with some other moves with a
three a four before he must play for his
right with that this is now very nice
well the computer wants to take with the
bishop that seems okay well it has some
points it has some points but I take
should be high now isn't it and I just
it is also good okay
no I went through key area I'm not 100%
sure about this move maybe it actually
helps wide a bit to trade the rooks it's
possible this is I don't think such a
great idea
it gives it gives to the mighty the
square or maybe even that is not bad
check okay we had a trade going and now
this yeah and this is a weird situation
I play g5 now first idea was this but
he's got g4 of course and I'm not sure
if it was helpful for me to to provoke
this this weakening I can just drop back
and well this is a good position for
black but I'm not sure if it was really
worth spending to move I'm provoking the
Jeep on I played that one this actually
there is the submission page five I was
I was a bit unsure about the shack but I
can take here yeah yeah that's very
important it keeps g5 protected and
gives black a win this is of course very
helpful as a dead PCM b1 so still I was
a bit irritated I was what I didn't
really appreciate is check that I can
take here I was always thinking that it
must be something like that
adhere it yeah that's even good for why
damn computer gives whiter whiter win
him yeah my King is so open so it was
good but I need to take on d2 I had
actually thought that I could play this
and just continue from them it's
certainly not bad for black but Bishop
h5 was strong
ok went went with this and now this
movie I'm computer does not like it ok
mm-hmm computer wants to play h6
something like that
just keeping everything yeah okay I
wasn't sure I thought Knight f3 and
maybe I can now do something with this
with this weekend pawn structure for
example if I would let's say get trains
Queens traded trains Queen at Queens
traded and the bishops also then I would
have a quite noisy endgame with lots of
pawns on on light squares but that's not
happening anytime soon this is what why
I needed to do this this I think leads
to some trouble yeah and c3 probably and
probably it's not good I don't know I
just went back the computer wants to
play Knight a6 and possess this is much
much better leading to win for black
that's remarkable
I don't understand it at all why this is
some great price is so great instead of
knight c6 yeah it covers c7 as this may
be the problem
computers are minus 2.5 so like blankets
totally winning
maybe but it's it's not so easy to make
a movie ever wide if you play something
like that I can go here and winning I'm
winning instantly trying to do that here
covering attacking here yeah okay it's
excellent it's excellent friend like
okay and here in fact c4 was right this
strange moves with the rebels okay and
the computer says that this is a big
mistake
interesting yeah okay it's it's just
it's tactics I thought that that I'm
just good here but okay the computer
points out the capture intending to
answer to play that and know that two
pieces hanging with a good position for
wide so again a position where white is
so yeah we're white wasn't in big
trouble but the computer shows still
some very tough defense CD 5 even being
good for for wide but this is now no
good right and takes takes and measured
before winning yes so on here was the
problem okay was not really having so
much time available but this is really
we had this night a six months yeah
maybe am it's also related to this this
move would see for that I then can play
can play like that yeah still a bit
strange
six hmm yeah very complicated very
complicated villain game Ian I'd like
could they'd like to point out four
people playing this is white if you face
with that you should start with this
move actually it has an interesting
point the the main point being that
Bishop c5 is not a rain check and this
means black now needs to readjust
somehow for instance black can't can't
play Knight f6 year but after that he's
got some options that are not some
options are not available on anymore
after that
97 of course the the easiest one or the
most obvious one okay that was an
interesting game thanks for watching